after weeks of waiting the Solar Impulse  2 took off into the night pilot Andre  Borschberg will steer the plane from  Nanjing in China to Honolulu in Hawaii  that means six days and eight thousand  kilometres non-stop in the air and a  world record if all goes to plan no  solar powered plane has ever flown this  far on board Bosh bag can only take 20  minute naps way we are not you of course  exactly how them the the weather look  like so the team on the ground will work  and help me to steal this airplane and  tippets in the right weather conditions  bad weather had kept wash bag from a  temptingly Pacific leg for almost six  weeks the journey circumnavigating the  globe started out in Abu Dhabi this leg  is the longest on the trip none of the  previous stretches were over 20 hours on  Twitter bosch bag said it was the flight  of his life but the former Swiss Army  fighter pilot said he was confident  about his Pacific journey